uh  [Music]  [Music]  omega  [Applause]  [Music]  at 1800 hours our cyber buyers will  invent all american cyborgs putting them  completely under the control of a  megaforce  the detonator before you is connected to  a nuclear bomb within the city of los  angeles  once the virus strikes detonate it and  your mission will be complete  forever  i guess that means you guys  i've never trusted an android until  today  it's been an honor serving with you my  voice commendable i will initiate my  shutdown procedure before the virus hits  me  you're hurting me  that virus is pretty fast  [Music]  approximately 30 seconds after  detonation  i'll kill you at 20.  unlikely  oh  [Music]  [Music]  huh  [Music]  uh  [Music]  [ __ ] robots  [Music]  you